and they will take their swings off of
john means making his fourth start since
coming off the il he's been about six
weeks on the il with that shoulder to
get a little bit sore on him but boy he
has been really good john means on the
hill and the first pitch swung out and a
drive back into the left field corner
that will one hop the wall and luke lowe
is on his way to second base so welcome
to the range lineup on the very first
pitch of his very first game in a rave
uniform he rips a double into the left
field corner yandy diaz to bat
and yandy diaz another first pitch swing
this one softly into left center
mullet's charging hayes charging
and austin made the catch and there is
no advancement from lupo from third a
phenomenal play by austin hayes
when you get cedric mullins and you get
austin hayes in the same outfield
together there's not many balls that's
going to drop in for the tampa bay rays
taking them out tonight will be
left-handed ryan yarbrough making his
17th start of the season looking for win
number seven
getting that starting nod for the race
because of so many injuries to that
pitching staff and cedric mullins greets
him with a first inning blister to left
field
a hit for mullins who came into today
tied for the major league lead and has
just taken it over
with number one thirty one mullins a
major base stealing threat at first
there he goes
and there he is
another steal for said that's number 21.
right now yarbrough just worrying about
ryan mount castle who's been red hot
that ball into left field well struck
luplow will have to play it on a hop and
the rbi streak is alive in the first
inning
it took him a grand total of one swing
to keep that up
the hit streak and ate the rbi streak at
seven and the oriole lead at one nothing
and enough length on his back to drive
it out in front of the left fielder luke
lowe cedric miles with two out no doubt
he was gonna score and ryan meltcastle
continues to swing the bat well and
wilmar goes set to lead off the second
here
and he's going to bunt that ball
barehanded pickup attempt by franco and
he cannot make the connection faces mike
zanino right-handed batter
zenito shoots it into left
that ball will hop to the wall
zenino
moves into second and margaux as he went
to third and rounded the bag lost his
footing
but manages to get back just in time
in between third and halt change up
stayed up he hung it zanino
all over it then here's the throw
you know it was just a turn and throw
there was no look whatsoever and
it's a chopper
first base side and nobody out the ball
loose on the toss to first margaux has
scored
zanino crosses the plate
and how about that
that ball
traveled maybe
60 feet
and there was no play on on camera you
were not going to get him on this play
at all that ball's just tapped into the
ground
once he got by means forget it he's not
going to be able to beat kiermeier to
the bag
compounded that mistake
with not catching the baseball here's
pedro sebarino with two down
and a first pitch fly ball out to right
from severino margot to the wall and
gone
oh pedro severino this has been
a post all-star break surge to remember
five home runs
since the break for sebby and he ties
the game at two with an opposite field
blast against franco hitting it 213 on
the year he's got 11 home runs
bronco goes the other way this ball will
get down this is trouble
bronco trying to dig for two here and he
will
walk his way in the second base michael
franco
just
dunked it in for double number 21.
savarino goes opposite way for a home
run now an opposite way
base hit double
for michael franco and all this with two
out because yarbrough got the first two
outs very quickly richie martin's first
home at bat
this ball pulled fair inside the bag
and richie martin has his first hit in
two years it is a run scoring double
and the orioles two out of salt of
yarbrough continues
three to two baltimore as the birds take
the lead back well good for richie
martin didn't hit it very hard but you
know what he hit it in the right place
over the plate hooks this ball right
down the line this is where the
struggles were for the oils in the last
two series
against the tigers the orioles only hit
185 but runners in scoring position as
michael franco lumbers around third base
and scores
here's austin hayes
and this ball is slug by austin hayes
deep to left field loop blow to the wall
and it's gone
austin hayes
certified southpaw masher
another long ball against a lefty
austin's 12th in total of the season and
the orioles are teeing off against
yarbrough and now jorge mateo up looking
for his first hit as a member of the o's
and mateo jacks one to center field
keermeyer weighs back
and it's over his glove jorge mateos
flying for three
and he is in there
his first oriole hit is a dead center
field rbi tripled
a little breaking ball that he struck
out on his last time and you could tell
he gets all of this from straight away
center field keermeyer has a shot at it
he goes back and leaps up and ball just
over his glove
i mean just by inches two men on
one out and the potential tying run at
the plate in nelson cruz
there's a long one deep into left center
that baby is gone home run off the bat
of nelson cruz
cruz connects a three-run shot
and just like that this game is tied at
five
well that didn't take long
that fastball middle in and look at
nelson cruz he is all over this pitch
very little
movement at the plate he stays so quiet
and calm and then explodes all over that
baseball and just like that you get into
the baltimore bullpen good things happen
bases loaded nobody out tied top of the
eighth inning
liner that's going to be a fair ball up
the left field line
phillips scores
kiremeyer will cross the plate
here it is that ball ripped and how
about that that's a play that could have
been made mateo i mean then you've got a
chance at a double play so
with minutes second and third wander
franco bats
ground ball up the middle that's going
to go through
luke lowe scores
throw to the plate as cruz scores
standing up
the rays tack on two more
now it's nine to five as franco comes
through to drive in a couple
liner in the center that's going to drop
for a base head
crossing the plate wander franco
that is charged to tate and the raids
lead 10 to five
ground ball
grabbed by choi head covers and the rays
win and the offense coming back roaring
back from down 5-2 to score eight runs
over a three-inning span and
beat the orioles rather soundly in the
end